i'm happy life is good uh ariana grande
is happy all right
because she got engaged to dalton gomez
at the end of 2020
after a whirlwind romance but now a
source is telling e.t that while the
couple is very in love
some of their friends think the
engagement was rushed
it was like so crazy our source says
that the lovebirds have been spending
a ton of time together since getting
engaged and keep their love
pretty low-key and private but the
source adds quote
they're very in love right now but
friends think the engagement was
somewhat rushed and are skeptical that
the relationship will
ultimately be short-lived no matter what
i'm grateful
ari and the luxury real estate agent got
engaged
just nine months after news broke that
the two were dating
the thank you next singer shared the
news on december 20th
posting this pic of her diamond and
pearl engagement bling on instagram
alongside the caption forever and then
some
i feel your love every day romance
rumors first sparked in february 2020
and they made the relationship public in
may when dalton made an appearance in
her music video with justin bieber for
stuck with you
at the time a source told et that they
were in a really good place
as they quarantined together in la amid
the coronavirus pandemic
the source also said that ahri's past
highly publicized romances
made her cautious when it came to
opening up about her personal life
you know like her previous very very
public engagement to pete davidson
in 2018
ariana has had some hesitation being so
public about her relationship with
dalton
as she's seen how that has worn on her
past relationships
but thankfully for all us ari fans
that hasn't stopped her from sharing a
snippet of her love on the gram
or from letting her man help her out
with filming fun videos promoting her
rain on me music video with lady gaga
it'll be raining all summer but we'll
surely be dancing as it does
we're soaking wet but hopefully i'm
broadly positive
back to you